Music: The Way I Do - Bishop Briggs
- If we wanna turn this place right
We have to speak as one united group.
- Who's in?
- Are you insane!?
- No she's angry!
- We're all angry.
- You done a girl wrong Mr Caputo,
and we want justice.
- To whom it may concern,
We the inmates of Lichfield,
are human beings.
We are protesting the abusive conditions
under which we are being held.
- We're gonna give 'em a show
- Whooo!
- We're gonna be super famous!
- Don't forget to smile.
- Do you get what's going on here?
- We get beat for no reason,
- we're stuffed four in a bunk like we factory chicken,
- We're denied basic humanity.
- How can I help?
- People ain't gonna like you.
- Story of my life.
- You do what you gotta do,
you don't owe nothing to no one
- My god!
- We have the chance to rule hard up in here.
- Y'all don't wanna rule?
- You see a problem, you deal with it
- This IS my home and I'm gonna fight for it.
(Screaming)
- We get to make demands.
- No idea is a bad idea.
- Ice cream sundee bar!
- Latin class!
- An anti gravity chamber,
we could float around and do
flips and stuff.
- Ok! some ideas ARE bad ideas!
- Tell this woman what we want.
We wanna be motherf***in taken serious
- Hell yeah!
- That's right!
(Music)
- The only way out, is for us
to come together.
- Excellent idea!
- Whooo!
(Music)
There's more strength in a single unified message
(Slow) - Mighty, we are ready to receive you.
(Music)
(No audio) (End)